la télé elle est à 50 euros monsieur la
table est à vendre aussi elle est à 10
euros et l'autre c'est un support pour
fixer la télé au mur
ok on fait un tour et après on va
afficher
Géraldine est une habitude des brocantes
après de nombreux rendez-vous en
Eure-et-Loir c'est la première fois que
cette lessienne vont dans les Yvelines à
Villepreux à 13h à l'avait déjà écoulé
une bonne partie de son stock son secret
le sourire la politesse dire bonjour et
voilà si un coup de cœur des fois
négocient je dis oui après ça c'est trop
bas je dis non donc ça dépend mais voilà
j'avoue je suis contente parce que ce
matin c'était bien plein et là
actuellement non je suis contente
vêtements vaisselle jouet livre il faut
farfouiller pour faire de belles
découvertes des instants que beaucoup
apprécient cette période d'inflation et
post covid les petits prix attirent la
variété la qualité et les petits prix
bien sûr je marchande bon ça dépend
honnêtement un Euro 2 euros on va pas
marchander mais à partir de 5 6 voilà on
essaye de grappiller un petit euro
les gens trouvent des articles pas chers
et puis je trouve que c'est convivial et
jouer en fait il y a beaucoup beaucoup
de de petites choses à dénicher qu'on
trouvera pas effectivement en magasin et
puis avec la passion
il y a vraiment la possibilité de
trouver quelque chose d'assez abordable
on fait des petits prix donc c'est plus
pour des encombrer et des mes enfants
aussi dans la dans la démarche il y a
possibilité de négocier le but c'est de
repartir avec moins que ce dont on est
venu voilà les brocantes à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ce n'est pas
terminé prochain rendez-vous Maurepas et
Montigny-le-Bretonneux les bonnes
affaires vous attendent